ich melde mich hier von der gamescom bei
der alles anders ist als in den letzten
jahren denn zum ersten mal werden die
gamer nicht mehr wegen ihrem body
geschämt sondern für ihren
stromverbrauch ist ihr bewusst dass du
eine umwelt sauber ist dass mir bewusst
aber es ist mir egal
[Musik]
die gaming szene verbraucht ja unfassbar
viel strom
richtig aber ich will bei meinen eltern
und bezahlen das okay dann ist es okay
wenn man genau also ich find's gut dass
meine eltern mich auch bei meinen hobby
unterstützen auch beim streaming und so
da wird auch nicht strom verballert die
sogenannte spaß umlage ja richtig genau
zu hause die rechner ausgemacht während
du hier bist
wir haben der energiekrise ihr müsst den
stromverbrauch reduzieren
das stimmt aber es gibt auch andere
quellen wo man den stromverbrauch
reduzieren kann bekommt er einen strom
dann weiß ich nicht ist egal spezial
damit hat sich das nicht sieht sich
stunden zog so am tag
10h ungefähr acht bis zwölf so am
wochenende gern mal 24 stunden durch
glaubst du denn die gamer sind insgesamt
bereit darauf zu verzichten ich glaube
dass er nicht also ich kenne da doch
einige die sind wirklich deutlich mehr
spielen und teure sachen ganzen tag
spielen und nicht bereit sind darauf zu
verzichten
sollte man den einfach den stecker
ziehen
[Musik]
schwierig ich bin mir nicht sicher was
sie machen wenn sie nicht sagen können
das sind irgendwie anderen plätze und
oder so was anstellen also du meinst es
ganz gut dass die meisten gamer einfach
zu hause rumhängen und nicht der
gesellschaft zu last fallen nein so
würde ich das nicht sagen dass es sonst
das nicht gemeint ist doch das war schon
so gemeint könnt ihr bitte die
lichtschwerter ausmachen hier müsste man
den stromverbrauch denken wir sind in
der krise läuft mir leid es ist jedoch
nur quatsch
können sie mal den ganzen zockern
erzählen was sie vor 30 jahren so
gemacht haben in ihrer freizeit ja ich
habe freunde gehabt ich habe fußball
gespielt und ich es war einfach fußball
das ist das analoge
fifa-geschichte warum ich hier bin ist
dass ich irgendwann mal mit meinem sohn
hierher gekommen bin das war vor acht
neun jahren seitdem barriere mäßige und
heute ist das erste jahr war sehr
gemischt aus stellt für die hochschule
in kempten setzen da gehen wir müssen
weiter
und wieder einen alten menschen an die
zockergemeinde verloren traurige bilder
wir müssen irgendwo abstriche machen
also entweder aufhören zu zocken oder
aufwand pornos zu gucken
das zocken ja ja liebe zuschauer was vor
circa 30 jahren noch für eine einweisung
gereicht hätte verbraucht heute circa
sechs bis zwölf prozent des globalen
stroms
es sind wirklich düstere zeiten und
damit zurück ins studio
so kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
kanal hier danke euer gernot hassknecht
so ich gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen zschau